[Music]
um hey what
what what what can i get you hello sir i
would like a
ramen coke roman coke coming up
[Music]
hey where you from
oh all right baby i'm gonna see on the
dance floor girl
oh ah it's rum and coke it's gonna be
eight dollars eight dollars all right my
good man
let me oh my god i got it
just
all right okay all right i'll tell you
what
third time's the chime brother
yeah just take the card out keep that
open for me can you hang on to the vomit
will do
in fact let me get a tequila shot
brother actually make it two man one for
me
and one for you my good man
two tequila shots coming right up how
you doing here
all right nectar of the gods up in here
all right all right let's get that going
with that
all right cheers cheers
you want some help with that hold up let
me just try to get up in here
[Applause]
oh that's burning my tongue you know
what what ah
i'm gonna get you one of these yeah try
that anyway all right hey
you a genius let me get this going on
here
i just want my factory
all right move driver out there yep
hey yeah
so uh i'm worried about you oh now i'm
gonna tell you what i'm worried about
i'm worried that this club ain't popping
up the way it should be what what
cause i wait a second what uh oh
dj turn it up that's my trap right there
[Music]
hey man a bar is not the place for you
to be right now
wow
let me get two more shots of tequila
uh-uh sorry pal you're 86.
what how what and what that's let's go
buddy
first time i think it's like 87
as uh two guys in a heavyweight pout
yeah no it was the first time uh in a
heavyweight bout that
the two fighters ended up getting
married
hello my good sir i like to have two
shots out the king
[Music]
come on brother oh mark
oh man arrows